les chérit les chéris est-ce que des
quelqu'un veut parier je paye 10 comme
la dernière fois vous misé un euro je
vous donne 10 euros c'est à dire pour
apparier soit en les laissant sans joe
kubert 1000 wii parfait apprenti vous
permet au gardé sans qu'on ait à fait
moi je me sers jamais mon coeur ils sont
non mais c'est plat cela vous pariez sur
thomas sotto j'avais mal et je parie 10
euros sur thomas sotto donc si vous
perdez vous avez 10 euros si vous gagnez
vous gagnez sont absolument on a 10
euros si jean luc mylayne quoi dans tout
ça m'est arrivé tu récupères t'inquiète
pas attaqué je ne m'inquiète pas tomates
un gamin sur 5 euros sur thomas sotto
très bien à crever 20 sur toi on va sur
moi ah mais moi je avec moi c'est tu le
gagnes que deux bons subaru non mais non
c'est mon papa est ce vendredi 26 août
et chérir les chéris attention donc on a
on a tous à kelly voulait pas les
quelque chose oui sur qui
- bb oui vous va oui d'accord très bien
alors y'a que matthieu delormeau qu'à
payer les mails hashtag #civsocial celui
qu'on prendra au téléphone tout à
l'heure gagnera peut-être toute la somme
que je vais gagner c'est parti on y va
bien cinq fois en marche le match 2
points d'écart ou pas bien sûr alors on
est professionnel
à lagos moto m'a sans pression les lots
de labarde t'insulte académique mais
tout va mal j'avais pas mal parler
par contre tu es bon balles
d'échauffement quoi un tact rôle à
abraham fallait près ladite serviront
non c'est moi qui ait servi et je me
sers une fois chacun
[Applaudissements]
bah oui alors sous senghor non six comme
rogers je suis pas moi paris moi je
serais si à londres quand tu veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tout
[Musique]
il adore parce que c'était complètement
improvisé cette affaire on va voir
comment il ya il ya quelqu'un tout de
suite sur twitter qui va remporter la
somme globale
voilà que vous avez donnée donc voilà
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des vins des 10
des 40 euros
c'est très bien je suis très très
content